ce type là s'appelle michel folco et il
y a quelques années il a eu une drôle de
l'uby à chaque fois qu'il passait près
d'un photomaton et regarder derrière et
le regarder à l'intérieur il regardait
sur les côtés et jeter un coup d'oeil
par dessus dans les poubelles aussi et
s'il y avait des photos déchirées il
ramassait il en faisait collection il
ans remplissait des classeurs entiers
essayer de comprendre pourquoi des gens
détruisent et jettent leurs propres
images
certains le font parce qu'ils n'ont pas
bien compris le fonctionnement du
tabouret d'autres parce qu'ils vérifient
trop tard que leurs pièces sont bien
dans la fente il y en a qui ne savent
pas que l'appareil peut prendre quatre
photos différentes
il y a ceux qui se repaît n'y au moment
du flash
et puis il ya ceux qui ferment les yeux
ou regardent n'importe où et enfin il y
a les défauts de la machine et un tas
d'autres raisons
là qu'ils trouvent que leur tronche ne
va pas du tout à ce moment là il est les
chais où il est froid zuii les jette
et puis il y à des énigmes par exemple
ce type qui se fait photographier avec
une liasse de billets à la main qui a
l'air heureux et qui finalement jette la
photo quand même pourquoi est ce que
c'est de l'argent est ce que sa première
paye est ce que c'est son premier coup
et puis surtout dans l'histoire de la
collection de folco il n'ya l'histoire
du jeune homme mystérieux ce jeune homme
mystérieux folco a trouvé des photos de
lui tous les jours pendant des mois et
dont tous les photomatons de paris les
photos étaient parfaites n'y avait
jamais aucun défaut mais elle était
toujours déchiré est foutu à la poubelle
pourquoi la deuxième fois il est
question la troisième fois ça m'a
vraiment intrigué avait imaginé une
psychose c'est une forme de suicide que
plutôt que de filer une balle dans la
tête avait préféré des chasses à proto
en fait tant pis pour le rêve la réalité
était beaucoup plus simple
un jour folco a vu le mec sortir d'un
photomaton et ont refermé la porte à clé
c'était tout simplement le réparateur
qui après chaque réparation tester
lui-même la machine alors cette
révélation a cassé tout charme et depuis
folco a arrêté sa collection
c'est vrai quoi si on peut plus rêver
autant ignorer les photomatons est
rentré chez soi non